[Música]
El Congreso de Perú rechazó por segunda
vez el proyecto de ley para adelantar
las elecciones a octubre de 2023 pero el
partido oficialista Perú libre presentó
una tercera propuesta al respecto que
además incluye una consulta sobre una
asamblea Constituyente
El Congreso de Brasil eligió este
miércoles a los presidentes de la cámara
de diputados y del senado finalmente
fueron electos los candidatos apoyados
por el presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva unos nombramientos clave para la
futura gobernabilidad Tenemos reporte
desde Río de Janeiro que se acabe la
violencia policial en Estados Unidos es
lo que pidieron durante el funeral de la
afroamericano tire Nichols allí También
asistieron familiares de otras personas
que murieron a manos de la policía como
George Floyd y la vicepresidenta kamala
Harris defendió un proyecto de ley para
tener más control sobre los uniformados
Bienvenidos a las noticias que France 24
le dedica a América Mi nombre es María
Clara calle iniciamos en Perú donde un
grupo político insiste en un proyecto de
ley para adelantar las elecciones a
octubre de 2023 se trata del partido
oficialista Perú libre que presentó una
propuesta al respecto la tercera que
debatirá el congreso luego de que el
miércoles los legisladores hundieran la
idea de adelantar los comicios con 68
votos en contra y 54 a favor la
iniciativa de Perú libre incluye una
consulta popular para preguntarle a la
ciudadanía si quiere o no una asamblea
Constituyente una de las exigencias de
las manifestaciones anti gubernamentales
además de la renuncia de la presidenta
Dina boluarte y el adelanto de las
elecciones para que no sean en 2026 como
se tiene previstas escuchemos lo que
dijo uno de los legisladores sobre el
proyecto rechazado Porque queremos que
recogía lo esencial de la exigencia de
la ciudadanía en este es decir
elecciones adelantadas en un plazo
prudente y con reformas mínimas que
garanticen elecciones justas
transparentes y corregir los errores del
sistema político electoral de tal manera
que nos permitan que el próximo
presidente y el próximo congreso no
tenga las dificultades que hemos tenido
nosotros y que la crisis política no se
repita el presidente de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva se jugaba este
miércoles su gobernabilidad Pues el
congreso eligió a los presidentes de la
cámara de diputados y del senado un
cargo que se renueva cada dos años la
gran pregunta era qué tanta oposición o
respaldo tendría el mandatario en medio
de la división entre bolsonaristas y sus
aliados anteriormente de nuestra
corresponsal en Río de Janeiro Valeria
sacone nos explicó Qué cambios hubo en
la cámara y cómo hay que entender los
nuevos nombramientos para la
gobernabilidad de Lula
la reelección de Rodrigo Pacheco en el
senado y de Arthur Lira en el congreso
puede ser interpretada como una victoria
para el presidente Lula y una derrota
para el expresidente Jair bolsonaro de
hecho los analistas políticos hablaban
de tercera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales por la importancia que
tenía hoy esta votación en el primer día
del nuevo ciclo político de Brasil donde
Lula se enfrenta a un parlamento muy
conservador Rodrigo Pacheco al final ha
conseguido 49 votos frente a un Aliado
de bolsonaro mariño es muy importante
porque Pacheco se ha labrado la fama en
los últimos dos años como defensor de la
Democracia ha resistido a las embestidas
de bolsonaro contra las instituciones y
contra las urnas electrónicas y su
reelección representa un nuevo momento
político especialmente tras la invasión
de la plaza de los tres poderes en
Brasilia el pasado 8 de enero ya la
reelección de Arthur Lira en la cámara
de los diputados con 464 votos
representa un esfuerzo de pragmatismo
político porque recordamos
Arthur Lira representa el central el
grupo de partidos de Centro que
tradicionalmente apoyan en cualquier
presidente a cambio de favores políticos
el en la pasada legislatura apoyó a
bolsonaro de hecho fue muy criticado por
no haber dado continuidad a ninguno de
los más de 150 pedidos de impeachmen
contra bolsonaro pero ahora Parece que
va a apoyar el nuevo gobierno y de hecho
en la votación curiosamente estaban
juntos tanto el partido de los
trabajadores de Lula como el partido
liberal de bolsonaro
este miércoles se realizó en Memphis el
funeral de la afroamericano taiwnie
Nichols Quien murió por la paliza que le
dieron cinco policías de esta ciudad de
Estados Unidos en su Velorio la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris defendió el
proyecto de ley justicia policial George
Floyd que crearía un registro de los
agentes sancionados por Mala conducta
entre otras medidas al funeral también
fueron familiares de personas que
murieron a manos de la policía como el
propio Floyd y briona Taylor la historia
es de Ramiro cué Barberena
cientos de personas se acercaron a la
iglesia cristiana de Mississippi
Boulevard para despedir a tyrie Nichols
el protagonista del último caso de
violencia contra los afroamericanos en
Estados Unidos
hemos venido el primer día del mes de la
historia afroamericana
hemos venido en diferentes medios de
transporte a través de un clima y
condiciones viales traicioneros
transparencia total
responsabilidad y Reforma legislativa
integral
el homicidio de Nichols revivó
sentimientos de injusticia en la
comunidad afroestadounidense y llevó al
gobierno a tomar cartas en el asunto por
un lado la vicepresidenta kamala Harris
asistió al funeral de nicholes
este acto violento no buscaba la
seguridad pública no fue realizado para
mantener la seguridad pública
[Aplausos]
uno se tiene que preguntar si esto fuera
un interés para mantener la seguridad
pública tars Nichols debería estar aquí
hoy
no tenía él también derecho a estar
seguro Así que cuando hablamos de
seguridad pública entendamos lo que
significa en su forma
debería haber estado a salvo
por el otro la Casa Blanca anunció
reuniones con legisladores por el
proyecto de ley policial de George Floyd
este jueves el presidente recibirá el
representante y a un pequeño grupo de
miembros del concreción alcus aquí en la
casa blanca para conversar sobre la ley
de justicia y policía de George Floyd y
otras políticas compartidas
el proyecto tiene como objetivo de tener
las tácticas agresivas de aplicación de
la ley pero aún está pendiente por la
aprobación en el congreso Hugo calma
este miércoles en las calles de Haití
antes de la huelga general planteada
para el jueves en la que exigirán la
renuncia del Primer Ministro agelensei
ante un eventual proceso electoral en el
país volvió a pedir a la Organización de
Estados Americanos el apoyo de fuerzas
extranjeras para garantizar la seguridad
esto el mismo día que cuatro sospechosos
acusados de participar en el asesinato
del presidente Joel mois en 2021 serían
juzgados en Estados Unidos con ellos ya
son siete los sospechosos que están bajo
custodia estadounidense acusados de
tener relación con el magnicidio veamos
han pasado más de 18 meses desde el
asesinato del presidente haitiano
benelmois y ahora el departamento de
justicia de Estados Unidos dice que ha
acusado a cuatro hombres por el
asesinato James solas y Joseph Vincent
ambos con doble nacionalidad haitiana y
americana así como Alejandro Rivera
ciudadano colombiano han sido acusados
de Conspiración para cometer asesinato
el último sospechosos Cristian sanon
tiene doble nacionalidad al parecer
quería sustituir a mois y está acusado
de delitos relacionados con el
contrabando mois fue asesinado a tiros
el 7 de julio de 2021 en su casa de
Puerto Príncipe por lo que la policía
dice que fue un escuadrón de mercenarios
extranjeros según el departamento de
justicia de Estados Unidos en un
principio los sospechosos querían
secuestrar a Moisés pero los planes
habrían cambiado
se alega que el 6 de julio de 2021
solash Vincent Rivera y otros se
reunieron en una casa cerca de la
residencia del presidente mois donde se
distribuyeron armas de fuego y equipo y
solash anunció que la misión era matar
al presidente mois
los fiscales dicen que el complot se
urdió originalmente en Florida los
cuatro hombres van a ser juzgados en ese
estado después de que la investigación
haitiana se paralizara con los jueces
recibiendo amenazas de muerte en el
momento del asesinato de Moisés Haití ya
estaba lidiando con varias crisis que
entraron en plena ebullición tras su
asesinato y las bandas se han hecho con
el control de la mayor parte de Puerto
Príncipe
este miércoles sobrevoló el estado
estadounidense de Washington el que ya
es el último siete cuatro siete
construido en la historia la compañía
estadounidense boing entregó el primer
avión de este modelo en 1969 a la
aerolínea panam desde entonces se han
entregado un total de 1574 unidades el
que fue el primer avión de dos pisos una
aeronave que en un principio se empezó
como transitoria hacia los vuelos
Supersónicos y que desde Entonces
debería haber sido solamente un avión de
carga como este último construido
así llegamos al final de las noticias
Siguen con nosotros
[Música]